I hate to start on tough news but I got
some tough news for California I don't
know if you've heard this but California
Governor Jerry Brown so that the state
is now sixteen billion dollars in debt
yeah yeah he said it in a speech called
seriously let's legalize pot overnight
and even if we don't make up the deficit
we won't care we'll be in our boxers
eating ice cream
I guess we're broke I don't care
presidential race getting pretty nasty
in a new ad that just came out President
Obama calls Mitt Romney's former firm
Bain Capital a vampire that's what he
said yeah as a result teenage girls are
demanding a movie about Bain Capital
brooding dark Bain Capital for the first
time ever the new JCPenney catalog
features a gay couple yeah this is uh
this is historic cuz it's the first time
anyone gay has been spotted wearing
clothes from JCPenney
we
[Music]
and once they put them on there straight
magic those pants will change you
the CEO of Best Buy has lost his job
because of a sex scandal yeah apparently
the the Best Buy CEO was caught asking a
customer to extend his service package
[Applause]
you know you're in trouble when the
bananas like better get around I mean ah
I'm a better dick joke
[Applause]
don't think that's what she intended I
know Rihanna has changing topics now
Rihanna has unfollowed Chris Brown on
Twitter yeah yeah parently she suddenly
realized he was that Chris Brown I can't
believe it took this long Dalai Lama has
said some pretty interesting stuff in a
new interview that just came out the
Dalai Lama said his biggest fear is
getting eaten by sharks yeah the the
Dalai Lama said his second biggest fear
is getting stuck talking to Richard Gere
[Applause]
Richard Gere ever due to this crowd get
him I found this fascinating at the
Miami zoo the orangutans have been given
iPads to play with I give you a right at
times iPads to play with yeah when the
children in China who make the iPads
heard the news they said this is
[ __ ]
yes
according to a recent survey they just
came out 14 percent of people 14 percent
say that they think sex lasts too long
those people are called inmates
[Applause]
I'm greeting well-wishers after that
thank you so much I appreciate it